A final problem I want to mention can be called the Traceability Problem.
The code of the program that uses a design pattern does not
necessarily make explicit that you're actually using the pattern.
You don't have to use the names of the classes taken from the book.
And, as you saw, there were lots of options with respect to implementation.
Consequently, somebody reading the code may not realize you're using a pattern.
Therefore, there's an extra obligation on you as a developer for documenting and
using certain naming conventions, so it's obvious what's going on.
If you're not careful, this can lead to increased the failure to
do this documentation can lead to increased fragmentation of the code,
having to do with the additional classes and methods which patterns introduce.